It sounds like a cliche but the one word
keeping chief executives up at night is
disruption. If you're the CEO of a big
company all it takes to get you paranoid
is to hear that Amazon is about to
invest in your sector. For example when
Amazon acquired online pharmacy PillPack for less than a billion dollars
last year leading brick-and-mortar
rivals Walgreens and CVS instantly lost
11 billion dollars in market value. So
it's no surprise that CVS spent 69
billion dollars to buy health insurer
Aetna. Why do they do that?
It was a clear response to Amazon's
plans to enter the business of selling
prescription drugs online. The fear that
Amazon or other tech giant's such as
Google, Facebook, Apple or even Uber can
muscle their way into any sector is
forcing legacy companies to take risky
bets on big acquisitions. That's the only
way they can stay relevant and fight the
disruptors. For example, IBM made its
biggest acquisition in its 107 year
history by buying an open-source
software company called Red Hat for
thirty four billion dollars the logic of
this deal is very simple. The lucrative
cloud computing business is dominated by
Amazon Web Services and Google if IBM
wanted to catch up in this business it
needed to make a big acquisition. The
other big disruptor has been Netflix the
TV streaming company has forced a number
of telecom and media companies to forge
new alliances to stay relevant in their
businesses. Boring telecom company AT&T
agreed to pay a hundred and eight
billion dollars to buy Time Warner
that's the owner of HBO and CNN. Last
year Disney and Comcast entered into a
bidding war to buy most of Rupert
Murdoch's 21st Century Fox. At the end
disney prevailed but still comcast ended
up buying european broadcaster Sky. We
should expect more of these kinds of
deals. Cash is cheap due to historically
low interest rates and many companies
have a ton of extra cash on their
balance sheet thanks to Donald Trump's
corporate tax cuts. This tax bill is
incredible. The conditions to make big
deals
are as good as ever.